the great one mark levin's brand new
book american marxism not only
did it debut week one on the new york
times bestseller list no
mark's hardcover sales that's only
hardcover
uh sold over
000 copies now
that number does not include ebooks a
lot of people
buy their books and they read it on
whatever tablet or
ipad they may have or even their phones
it doesn't include audio books
it is an incredible achievement mark's
new book
is now outsold the next
15 books combined
in the country that's that's an
incredible
uh statistic he's the host of life
liberty levin
and his own nationally syndicated radio
show i call him the great one mark
levine
well you know i did tell you
in my humble opinion we've been friends
for decades
uh i said mark when you sent me an early
copy
i said i think this is your best book
and i
and you know what a fan i was of
everything from liberty and tyranny to
rescuing sprite even but
this is a timely book for this moment
tie it together to the moment today
what's happening in the country that's
the six
month mark of joe biden
over for i can't even tell you we're
almost at 500 000 books now
in uh in a relatively short period of
time i'm going to tell you what's going
on
i was part of the reagan revolution as
part of the tea party movement
i was part of the trump revolution there
is a
massive movement afoot it's not under
the radar people just aren't looking at
it
the silent majority is not going to be
silent anymore the american people are
furious with what's happening to their
country and by american people i mean
all american people who love this
country regardless of their color their
religion their background
red-blooded americans they are sick and
tired of what they've seen in the first
six months of this administration
they don't like the way they're being
treated by the elites in the media
they don't like being looked down upon
by these phony professors who they bring
on tv
who trash them they are disgusted with
the teachers unions parents all over
this country can't believe what's
happened to elementary schools and
secondary schools
parents go broke to send their kids to
college another coming home on
thanksgiving or
other days and they don't know what's
happened to them we are paying for our
own demise with tenured marks as
professors and administrators
for schools that are turning on our
founding in our history
americans love their history americans
love their history the good the bad and
the ugly
americans are sent all over the world to
fight wars for people who do not look
like them
america's borders are wide open we have
a president united states with violating
our immigration laws who signs executive
orders like his benito mussolini
we're sick and tired of hearing from san
francisco nancy pelosi
and new york city uh chuck schumer what
they intend to do to our court system
those courts belong to us
attacking separation of powers and our
constitutional construct
we're tired of the way the family is
trashed in this country
the family we're tired of where private
property rights are treated in this
country
we're tired of a lot of things going on
in this country now we
the people we are peaceful you won't
find us running around with molotov
cocktails you won't find us attacking
cops we defend the cops
you won't find us burning cities and so
forth and so we're not mostly peaceful
we're 100
peaceful but we are pissed off
and we have had enough and we're done
talking about it
the idea that a book like this sells
four hundred thousand copies in one week
and is well on the way to a half a
million
i've been in these movements before i
saw what happened with liberty and
tyranny in the tea party movement
we know our history we are a great
people and we have people in this
country we haven't contributed a damn
thing to it
and not a damn thing to it trying to
tear it down
and redistribute wealth they sound like
they're soapbox marxist
going on and on about we don't provide
this we don't provide that and
bernie sanders is going to provide it
and aoc is going to provide it
they don't know a damn thing about this
country they use
the benefits of capitalism to attack
capitalism
they use liberty to attack liberty they
use the constitution to attack the
constitution
i've been around a long time and i'll be
damned if i'm gonna sit still for this
and they don't understand the american
people the american people are not going
to roll over and play
dead the american people are going to
speak out and let me tell you what's
going to happen in 2022
with the mansion types and the others
who pretend to be moderates who play
footsies
with these american marxists you're
going to get blown out
in fact every damn one of you is going
to get blown out so
kiss your career goodbye you may have
power now
you may be trying to force your will on
the american people now
but it will not last that's what's going
on in this country
i feel it and i know it that's all i
have to say
great one um i wanted to say this about
the book last thing if you don't mind
six ch seven chapters in the book
you lay out the case of the challenges
this great country faces
at at this current moment in time
chapter seven is over ten thousand words
which is a lot for a chapter in any book
and we choose liberty that's the answer
and i wrote you when i read it i said
that's the answer
great job sir congratulations well done
and
thank you sean god bless you
bookstores everywhere american marxism
life liberty and levin
every sunday night number one show right
here on the fox news channel